on reparle de tous là ce soir avec notre
invité Mériadeck rafray journaliste
spécialiste des questions de défense
bonsoir merci beaucoup d'avoir accepté
notre invitation sur France 24
concernant tout d'abord la fourniture à
l'Ukraine de ces nouveaux systèmes de
défense entier aérienne c'est
effectivement la priorité absolue comme
le dit le secrétaire général de l'OTAN
yenstolberg exactement j'avais aussi
noté ces termes je t'offe jamais rien
dit priorité au soutien de la défense
solaire ukrainienne on a vu là que
depuis lundi mardi et ce mercredi les
Russes sont renoués avec les campagnes
de missiles de tir de missiles contre
les infrastructures dans la profondeur
du territoire ukrainien le président
aussi noté mentionné l'usage des drones
donc on voit que les Ukrainiens sont
confrontés en fait ils doivent ce que
les militaires appellent créent une
bulle de déni d'accès c'est le terme
technique employé pour empêcher en fait
les miss que les missiles ne puissent
atterrir et soit intercepter
de d'arriver sur leur cible c'est
quelque chose d'assez compliqué à faire
visiblement les
Ukrainiens avaient déjà du matériel que
du matériel ancien soviétique les fameux
S300 vous savez qui sont qui viennent
justement de la Russie soviétique
aujourd'hui les Russes envoient un
mélange de missiles plus ou moins
performant plus ou moins moderne les
plus modernes étant de type Iskander ou
calibre qui sont difficiles très
difficiles même à arrêter donc il y a
une menace multiple et en même temps il
y a la menace des drones qui elle est
une menace plus tactique plus de courte
portée si vous voulez et le président y
a fait référence donc là le l'enjeu pour
les Ukrainiens c'est d'arriver à mettre
suffisamment à adresser un maillage en
fait à la fois de radar et de missiles
anti-missiles très rapidement donc les
Américains ont dit qu'ils allaient
livrer des systèmes de longue portée les
Allemands
voilà c'est ça on va pas trop rentrer
dans la technique parce que c'est un peu
compliqué les Allemands avec le système
Iris qui est un système intermédiaire
les Français projet par exemple ont déjà
déployé en Roumanie ce qui est ce qu'on
appelle le mandat le mandat c'est un
système de défense solaire qui est très
puissant qui couvre qui peut aller
jusqu'à 100 km de hauteur 100 km², c'est
très important et puis le président a
évoqué des systèmes qui permettent de
détecter et de riposter contre des
drones qui sont une menace plus plus
active
selon vous Emmanuel Macron a passé à la
vitesse supérieure ce qu'on sait que en
fait la France va la livraison par la
France était quand même relativement
limité par rapport à d'autres pays on
pense notamment au Royaume-Uni qu'est-ce
qu'il
voulait globalement quand même les
Occidentaux sont confrontés aujourd'hui
à une problématique qu'on a déjà un
petit peu évoqué c'est que les arsenaux
qui étaient directement disponibles sur
étagère les systèmes sur étagères et je
dirais dans les surplus bien aujourd'hui
il n'y en a quasiment plus les chaînes
les chaînes industrielles doivent se
remettre à produire en économie de
guerre pour reprendre une expression une
expression du président
que ce soit aux États-Unis en Allemagne
ou en France chacun avec son échelle si
vous voulez donc il y a quand même un si
il y a quand même un problème global
donc là
exactement d'ailleurs le président a
répondu à une question de la journaliste
qui lui a dit écoutez on fait ce qu'on
peut mais nous aussi on ne peut pas trop
dégarnir nos armées vous savez qu'on a
déjà livré 18 annonces 16 heures on en
avait 76 je crois en stock c'est à peu
près 20-25% du potentiel de nos armées
et comme vous le savez les armées disent
qu'elles sont équipées de manière
échantillonnaire donc c'est pour vous
dire qu'on est quand même un peu
contraint d'ailleurs les six prochains
canons César qui vont être livrés enfin
dont la discussion est en cours ce sont
des canons qui euh
c'est une sorte de quelques semaines
parce que c'est des canons qui étaient
prévus pour être exportés en direction
du Danemark donc c'est une c'est une
commande qui ne devait pas aller à la
France toute la question est de savoir à
quel de quelle façon les le l'industriel
qui fabrique ce canon va pouvoir
accélérer la cadence euh voilà et ça
c'est un problème industriel des stocks
ça prend combien de temps de
réapprovisionner disons euh
vous avez d'autres gendarmes oui vous
avez deux types de stock vous avez des
stocks pour fabriquer pour fabriquer
l'arme et les stocks pour fabriquer des
munitions parce que si vous avez pas de
munitions vous pouvez apporter des armes
ça sert pas grand chose donc pour
accélérer la fabrication de ces armes ça
va prendre du temps parce qu'il faut il
faut acheter financer et mettre en place
des chaînes industrielles
supplémentaires pour les obus je pense
que c'est plus rapide mais on part nous
en tout cas en France on part de de très
bas puisqu'on était dans un dans une
école dans une une comment dirais-je on
était dans une perspective de de corps
expéditionnaire de guerre contre les
terroristes donc les les stocks pour
faire ce type de guerre de haute
intensité tu es relativement limité
alors avant même cette annonce de
d'Emmanuel Macron ce soir chez nos
coffrets de France 2 l'Ukraine avait
salué à l'ouverture d'une nouvelle ère
avec l'arrivée vous l'avez évoquée du
système irrité en provenance donc
d'Allemagne et de la livraison dans une
prochaine de ces fameux nassam
américains tout cela combiné ça pourrait
effectivement faire la différence sur le
terrain il faut être très prudent parce
que ça fait des semaines que certains
spécialistes expliquaient que la Russie
était avec déjà tiré tous ces missiles
et là on se rend compte qu'elle m'a
attiré plus d'une centaine en 48 heures
même certains disent 300 on a du mal à
savoir exactement quels sont les
chiffres donc je crois qu'il faut être
très prudent sur
sur les équilibres possibles il est
clair en tout cas que là l'Ukraine doit
aujourd'hui tout faire pour protéger ses
sites sensibles ces sites vitaux
cruciaux comme vous le savez en fait les
Russes ont tirées de manière délibérée
sur notamment des infrastructures
énergétiques et nous sommes au bord de
l'hiver en hiver qui vous le savez sera
très très rude dans cette dans cette
période de l'Europe continentale donc
évidemment les Russes les pardons les
Ukrainiens doivent être c'est une course
de vitesse enclenchée pour protéger ses
sites et ensuite un équilibre va se
faire entre la capacité et la qualité
matériel des radars et des missions
antimissiles et ceux qui seront envoyés
par les Russes comme je vous disais tout
à l'heure les missiles russes il y a du
du de l'ancien et il y a du très moderne
donc voilà comment est-ce que vous
interprétez cette centaine de missiles
tirées par la Russie on est clairement
aujourd'hui dans un nouveau tournant de
la guerre me semble-t-il
c'est une réaction à la poussée
ukrainienne qui a commencé début
septembre et qui a conduit les Russes
quasiment d'eau mur dans un certain
nombre au Nord et au Sud en particulier
non c'est pas de la Fabrique parce que
pour pouvoir lancer ces centaines de
missiles tout ça était forcément
planifié au niveau militaire donc je
pense que c'était planifié
qui a qui nécessitait une préparation
militaire technique évidente si vous
voulez pour désigner les cibles pour les
trouver et pour mettre en place tout ce
système de lancement d'autant de
missiles c'est une opération technique
complexe pour les Russes et donc c'était
évidemment dans les tuyaux avant lundi
matin merci beaucoup mariadeck rafray
pour toutes ces explications ce soir